[Music]
while it's all well and good keeping up
with the exciting new releases sometimes
it's nice to play old favorites at least
that's what I like to do and it turns
out I'm not the only one I spoke to my
local and international colleagues about
what childhood games they like to replay
every year or so I was a teenager during
the heyday of JRPGs on the Super
Nintendo system and while I love games
like Final Fantasy 6 and chrono trigger
the games that probably made the biggest
impact on me was earthbound the combat
still feels fresh today like at the time
you couldn't see enemies in other games
and this was a JRPG that not only let
you see enemies before you fought them
it it let you sneak up on them you could
strategize how you were going to fight
these guys and when you were at a high
enough level you didn't even have to
fight them anymore you could just run
into them and you'd win but even more so
than the combat system it was the story
it was this weird mix of Americana and
surrealism that when paired with out an
amazing soundtrack just made it an
experience that I still think stands out
today as one of the greatest games of
all time that's why I keep playing it so
as a kid the only thing I had to play
games on was a 38 60 X pc and the first
game i ever played and the game that
taught me how to type was quest for
glory by ciara crystal glory is a Sierra
adventure game but it's an RPG hybrid as
well and it's like such a unique sub
combination of two genres that hasn't
been replicated to this day at all and
it's so many unique things about it so
you could play as three classes fighter
thief wizard but with all the SAT points
of stuff you could customize character
in an infinite amount of ways and you
could input your character through each
of the five games all the puzzles also
involve your RPG stats as well so you
could say break down a door or just use
magic or be a thief and sneak in
lockpick all that kind of stuff but
you're also doing real-time combat each
sort of game had its own combat system
and each game took place in such unique
locales we're talking about so dramatic
fairytale land Middle Eastern Arabian
Nights the African savanna and Slavic
sort of vampire mythology to this day
there's never been a game series that's
been so unique in sort of concept
mechanic and story that has been as
memorable to me
the quest for glory series and that's
why I play it all the time when I was
around six my mom brought home banjo
kazooie for the n64 and she and I played
it obsessively probably for four years
until i cooled down a little bit and
then to this day I play it once every
year she and I played together and it
was a really really important bonding
experience for me we kept a notebook we
kept track of all of Brent iltis with
answers for the the trial at the end of
the game which upon reflection is
probably not my favorite part of the
game but I loved it so much as a kid I'm
it's weird because platformers really
aren't the genre I gravitate to anymore
but banjo kazooie is when i return to
every single year try to beat my lowest
time to this day i think i've done it in
eight hours i'll keep playing until i
can get to around six hours the game i
returned to pretty much every year is
the legend of zelda majora's mask
ocarina of time always used to be my
favorite zelda but the older I get and
the more I play majora's mask the more I
appreciate how weird and how bold and
how creative it is you have three days
in this world to complete the game and
of course you can end up rewinding time
and starting things over and doing
certain quests different ways and
meeting certain people at different
spots and exploring termina all over the
course of just four major dungeons as
opposed to the usual seven or eight and
a zelda game but the thing is this game
is so side quest base and rewards you so
much for exploring and finding new masks
and exploring is weird gloomy dark
pretty depressing world that you're
rewarded almost every time you find a
new area our new character you talk to
or a new master fine even more so than
any other Zelda game it's rewarding to
just meet new people and find new places
and that's why it's a game I return to
time after time so my childhood like so
many of our childhoods was completely
defined by Disney and all their amazing
movies and lucky for us a lot of those
movies became video games I'm talking
jungle book lion king and my personal
favorite Aladdin it takes you some of
the best locations like you ain't never
had a friend like me Jeanie dream
sequence level and it's got really good
music from the movie being the youngest
of three sisters I was often not able to
play because I wasn't as good at the
game as they were and it's just kind of
like just always sectioned off to the
side the problem was like back then you
couldn't save the game you had to just
play it all the way through or leave it
running
didn't like that so they could beat the
game in one sitting and I couldn't now I
can beat the game in one sitting as long
as I'm practicing and doing a good job
and that's rad that's why I want to come
back to it because I can beat this game
I can take on Jafar and I can totally
take them out with some apples to the
face and if you can take down Jafar
you're treated to a really nice
rendition of I can show you the world
and who doesn't want that I've been
playing video games for almost 30 years
and I replay a lot of my favorites but
none more so than final fantasy tactics
I love the gameplay first and foremost
it's a very difficult strategy game but
you can also break it in a lot of ways
there's a lot of you know opportunities
to be creative with different classes
and just create different teams and just
kind of infinite replay value but I also
love it because it came at a time where
you know I played Final Fantasy 6 and 7
which had more modern settings than past
games which were set in like a medieval
world tactics brought that back and it
was also really great because it was
super tragic characters died all the
time and it's just a really impactful
story even you know I played it probably
seven times over now and it still gets
me every time my magic eight day of the
destroyer is a game I play every couple
of years I'd say even though it's a huge
RPG that takes tens of hours to play
it's a turn-based RPG where you have a
party you look out from a first-person
perspective and it's not the kind of
game you really see any more there are
something so delightful about playing
this brutally hard classic western RPG
you have a huge variety in the number of
classes you can choose there are dark
elves and necromancy sand dragons that
you can opt in and out of your party you
can tailor make it for exactly the way
that you want to play I remember playing
this game as a kid and my dad had played
it before me he printed out hundreds of
pages worth of manuals because there are
so much you need to reference you need
to figure out what kind of pie you're
going to build who the classes are what
can they upgrade until what level can
they upgrade where are the teachers for
the skills that you need for each of
your different classes it's incredibly
complex and in a way it's the kind of
complex that turns people off but for me
it's just super exciting and I love
getting back into the challenge every
couple of years
those are our picks but let me know down
in that comment section which game from
your childhood you like to revisit every
so often and why and we'll catch again
next time
[Music]
you
[Music]